voici robert smith des cure
bonsoir
robert smith nephew nous sommes très
heureux de vous avoir sur ce plateau
remercié alors ainsi des revenus pour
nous c'est tout votre jeu mais ce qui
vient de défiler en quelques en quelques
morceaux mais j'étais fan j'avais
j'avais su poster dans ma chambre au
grand art et sport de mon père eugène
succès n de banshee s'étaient mêlés
christophe coiffé comme ça qu'ils
achetaient où les trouver qu'est ce que
ça fait robert d'entendre toute son
oeuvre comme ça des filets en quelques
minutes
ça décoiffe
alors 2002 à berlin vous avez joué
l'intégralité de trois de vos albums sur
scène et ce concert plus des bonus dont
une interview de vous de 30 minutes
sortant double dvd
[Musique]
pour 2 dvd magnéto serge
une
mais
pour le doublé
des torrents alors van der slikke vous
avez 44 ans vous êtes né en 1959 à
blackpool au bord de la mer dans le nord
ouest de l'angleterre
et vous avez des souvenirs comme ça
parce que votre votre père filmer tout
en en super 8 et vous regardez des films
on vous voit courir sur la plage avec
des ânes à l'arrière-plan
vous allez voir une faut peut-être bien
informés qu'ils tombaient j'ai des
souvenirs du coup du sable de caen était
très petit de l'odeur des annoncé hier
soir oui c'est vrai c'était l'un des
aspects de la plage à blackpool fric et
encore des ânes qui coursent la plage de
la course pour vous vous souvenez quand
vous des terriers les vers de terre pour
les faire manger à votre soeur ben je
m'en souviens et c'est tout à fait mais
ils avaient toujours tendance à me
donner le vomi de ces animaux de manger
à moi alors 13 ans vous avez votre
première guitare et puis ensuite vous
montez vos premiers groupes fait
beaucoup à l'époque de reprise de jimmy
hendrix a alors 76 c'est l'arrivée du
punk des sex pistols
là vous montez votre groupe qui
s'appelle d'abord izik your en 77 et un
jour vous réagissez à une annonce dans
le journal
une annonce d'un label qui s'appelle en
deçà qui dit vous voulez vous devenir
une star
et là évidemment vous enregistrer une
cassette dans la salle à manger de vos
parents et ça marche
nous avons fait effectivement quelques
démos on a plutôt de proposer et met
enfin à la fin ils sont débarrassés de
ce qui ne l'est pas notre musique m'en
fallait hier cannes ça il voulait que
vous fassiez que dès que des reprises en
fait il voulait pas vos chansons
originales et puis alors ça ça vraiment
en frites et quand vous êtes arrivé avec
votre single qui s'appelait killing en
arabe
tuer un arabe alors évidemment ça fait
scandale dans la maison de disques est
en fait vous s'était inspiré par le
meurtre absurde
de l'étranger de meursault dans le
bouquin de camus mais c'est vrai qu'en
angleterre ce titre killing en arabe a
été récupéré par le national franz qui
est un petit peu en france le front
national une seule chose que je regrette
en toute ma vie c'est effectivement le
titre de cette chanson parce qu'à dix
sept thons il me semblait que tout le
monde s'intéresserait autant que moi
albert camus et où moscou prendrait le
look est existentiel de mains d'albert
camus et ce titre m'avait obsédé en tant
que coauteur mais évidemment on a
toujours on a pensé qu'il s'agissait
disons dans l'appel aux moeurs
possibilité mental alors ce qui est
sympa par contre c'est que au cours des
années j'ai pu faire connaître
l'existentialisme français à l'étranger
bien sûr vous avez fait beaucoup pour
pour cam est effectivement alors malgré
tout vous vous devenez rapidement culte
et autour de vous on assiste à
l'émergence de ce qu'on a appelé le look
gothique avec beaucoup de pulsions
suicidaires des pulsions homicide ni
liste deux choses le côté un peu
ténébreux lequel je pouvais présenter et
puis le groupe qu'ils aient un peu les
marioles ça a commencé comment votre
coiffure tous les dix ans j'écoute
toujours à sous et je recommence à zéro
et pourquoi vous avez décidé de vous
maquiller aussi raison que les acteurs
et les états ne présente de me permettre
de présenter sous un jour plus
flamboyant privé de mon maquillage je me
sens un peu plus réservés vous avez un
côté un peu lisse taylor poche tron est
quand même
ça
juste parce qu'à chaque quelque chose
tout le monde rigole et je suis pas
toujours sûr de confondre la blague
vous avez pris beaucoup de drogue un
robert ici non pas derrière vous vous
dites j'ai eu peur à force de me griller
les neurones et de pu reconnaître
personne
wahou être une bonne chose que j'ai pu
reconnaître comme le des situations de
danger
par exemple j'ai pu voir que je risquais
de me griller les neurones ou magie de
cette présence d'esprit voyez vous même
nature ne me permet pas de formuler une
opinion sur mes propres expériences
directement robert star est un exemple
pour des millions de jeunes
est ce que vous pourriez dire à la télé
que la drogue c'est pas bien disons que
on ne comprend pas toujours ce que c'est
la drogue
je ne dirais pas que toutes les drogues
sont mauvaises l'histoire nous a montré
qu' il ya des civilisations qui ont
utilisé des drogues afférentes
différentes fins et si elles sont
utilisées de manière positive ça peut
être une bonne chose mais la culture
occidentale diaboliser la drogue
à telle enseigne que maintenant on en a
fait quelque chose ne tourner
complètement médias bon le tabac par
exemple ça c'est une mauvaise romain
robert smith et on peut dire que vous en
tous les cas pour vous débarrasser de la
drogue la religion n'a été d'aucun
d'aucun secours
parce que vous aviez un frère aîné qui
était hippie qui étaient revenus d'asie
écrit et qui passait son temps à mettre
de l'encens la cuisine de vos parents et
c'est vrai que ça faisait tellement
d'histoires que la religion ne vous a
pas semblé une une vraie solution
ma famille était catholique et ça c'est
une bonne recette pour se transformer en
meubles jusqu'à la fin de ses jours
aurait dit je connais peu de gens que la
religion est rendue mais
heures ou plus heureux c'est grave quand
même ça désinvolte par rapport à ça mais
la notion de choix c'est quelque chose
qui m'a toujours intrigué
personnellement je n'ai aucune foi en
quoi que ce soit sauf ce que j'arrive à
voir de mes yeux est touchée de mes
doigts mais je sais qu effectivement des
gens qui ont une fois absolument
incroyable et j'ai eu envie
j'aimerais bien voir ça cette fois mais
au fond je me dis est ce que il ne faut
pas que de se bercer d'illusions vous
êtes comme ça chez d'arbres je suis en
partie d'accord avec ce qu'il dit la
fois pour moi doit être personnel intime
elle doit pas être dévoilés d'une mare
puis il ya des puciers aussi à qui on
peut en qui on peut mettre un peu tous
et tous ses espoirs la religion souvent
pour moi c'est celle et désespéré qui
ont besoin c'est peut être noble c'est
que si vous pensez pas que ces
désespérés non si aussi se situe ouais
ouais parce que vous vous êtes allé voir
un psy si vous aviez eu la foi vous
soyez allé voir un curé non répond voilà
je suis athée et si on veut régler le
problème
faisons en sorte que plus personne ne
croit en rien si ce n'est à lui même et
à l'être humain voilà et tout ce qui
au-delà spirituel machin ça c'est fait
pour manipuler le peuple pour manipuler
les gens s'intéressent qu'au 9e et faire
marche pouvoir et au nom de quoi de la
religion c'est la religion qui détruit
tout qui détruisent l'être humain la
religion ne détruis l'être humain à mon
avis et vous pensez pas
psychanalyste exactement pareil qui se
raccroche toxiques et réalise comme
avant se raccrocher aux curés et c'est
par ailleurs un petit monsieur ardisson
oui un psychanalyste c'est julie re
rentrer dans mon monde intérieur dans
toute mon histoire dans mon inconscient
et à travers ça c'est ma propre histoire
et à travers ça j'essaie d'en sortir
quelque chose
la religion c'est quoi si nos croyances
une croyance et quoi s'étonner je crois
plus à rien c'est aujourd'hui je crois
en quelque chose si je me raccroche à
quelque chose mais rien de concret vous
êtes déclaré robert smith je suis blasé
aujourd'hui je suis devenu blasé et je
me suis fait c'est terrible cette phrase
je me suis fait à l'idée que la vie
n'avait pas à être extraordinaire on
voit le monde en soit potentiellement
est un nombre absolument fabuleux rien
qu'à regarder nature c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire à la notion même
d'existence est extraordinaire et je ne
vois pas pourquoi il faut quelque chose
de plus que cela il suffit de regarder
les étoiles et vous avez des l'a déjà
toute la mairie du monde est pas c'est
vrai que le monde peut paraître horrible
mais il faut quand même se dire que dans
la plupart des cas les religions c'est
ça qui rend le monde horrible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je remercie ceux qui auraient cantona
deviendraient des meilleurs amis du
monde
alors aujourd'hui robert vous croyez
plus en rien ne vous avez quand même un
sens moral vous pourriez pas faire comme
morceau justement on en revient à
l'étranger de camus pour il pas faire
comme meursault allez tu as là justement
qu'il est quand même l'absence de dieu
ne signifie pas qu'il faut pas avoir de
moralité virtù la notion de moralité
pourquoi faut-il que la morale viennent
de dos ou d'un dieu un être humain peut
savoir ce qui est bon et ce qui n'est
pas beau c'est ma philosophie à moi et
avec des d'accord avec ça je suis
d'accord c'est le début surtout
magnifique
si les gens étaient comme ça à penser
comme ça
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu